it's a lot easier to actually write a  screenplay than you think it is might  not be good but most people talk about  writing screenplays but don't actually  write them I remember when I was in  college I spend most of my time in my  room writing screenplays really bad  screenplays but I was in my room doing  that when I probably should have been  studying there were a lot of people I  remember at parties who would talk about  writing and that they wanted to be  writer but I would always notice they  were out every time I would happen to go  out they would always be out I just know  that that there are people who talk  about what they would do if but they're  not actually doing the thing and so the  people who write them you're already  like in you know the top 10 percent  because you actually have written it